[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro masqué
de profit de lecture des éditions le
basque ça existe un masque de droit ce
que c'était je crois que c'était des
polars non du tout le mague attaque les
simpson eh bien on n'est pas le mot
d'agatha christie avec avec notre invité
du jour qui va dériver l'excellent
l'oeil rieur de ceux qui savent raconter
des histoires la respire la bonne santé
de ceux et celles qui aiment et soigne
la nature et puis alors peut-être un peu
intimidé parce que la première
télévision mais quand vous verrez ce
qu'elle a fait dans sa vie est l'un
d'eux fut beaucoup d'autres alors
valérie va l'ex a trois passions je peux
le dire comme ça c'est l'histoire ce
sont les histoires et ce sont les
abeilles et elle a réussi ce tour de
force de réunir depuis quelques années à
la ville ou plutôt à la campagne
s'occupe d'aider des abeilles portent le
casque le voile vareuse des apicultrice
et puis à la seyne si on peut dire et
publie des romans qui connaissent de
plus en plus de succès alors on va
parler du cinquième tome de sa série
crime et abeilles qui s'appelle dix
petits frelons et puis cette autre
passion c'est l'histoire et on va parler
de roman parce qu'elle nador notamment
napoléon qui se passe sous nos polos que
ça mal de diamant de waterloo
alors il est les deux des deux livres
d'ailleurs ce jeu si dieu sont publiés
aux éditions pas les mots dont on a déjà
essayé plus grand bien donc dans cette
émission on va pas laisser de livres
mais j'apprends que d'ici quelques mois
il va sortir le sixième tome 10 appels
mordu
gym sont bâtis les sorties des suicides
bell offre alors dont j'avais une
question que je suis au fond
l'apiculteur c'est un métier de fainéant
ça va se dresser au temps fou ça laisse
un temps fou l'hiver mêlant cité en été
on est très très pris la saison va être
un peu plus tardive parce qu il a fait
froid tardivement ce n'était pas le cas
du premier confinement vraiment on a été
très heureux parce qu'on fait des choses
de bonheur et donc nous quand vous
établissez votre temps travail comme ça
entre autres vous votre métier mais
aussi de sa fille vous avez une vie qui
s'appelle audrey aux tenailles comme
dans l'héroïne de réclame aussi la maman
c est bien ça se partage
je dirais c'est vraiment le timing qui
est très très important le temps pour
écrire le temps en attendant le temps
pour les abeilles et ça c'est la même
journée la plupart du temps quand c'est
l'été en tout cas donc vous avez des
journées de 48 ans toutes les mamans
alors on va parler la voix de ses dix
petits folle où on va parler de ses dix
petits frelons alors les frelons en
question ce sont à la fois des frelons
asiatiques ont mais on en croise
quelques uns dans deux romans et des
jeunes ados abîmés par la vie des jeunes
délinquants cours pour tout dire dont
s'occupe un prêtre le père larcher il
sort de deux père guy gilbert belle et
très franchement apprécié ce monsieur le
dit franchement donc j'ai apprécié au on
en parlera après parce que c'est très
amusant au modèle et dans l'est dans la
bouche de ce prêtre donc le mot frelons
n'a rien de péjoratif ans alors il se
trouve que audrey convient de citer
notre culte à leur votre héroïne qui
sont coude un immense chagrin parce
qu'elle vient de perdre son mari pour se
changer un peu les idées elle va partir
avec son ami francis lebel qui est
adjudant gendarmerie à la retraite et
ils parc à giverny pour suivre un stage
sur la gelée royale justement et bien
qu'organise se prête mais giverny et
bien ce n'est pas seulement le miel se
sont si les impressionnistes et c'est
surtout claude monet
qui a vécu dans c'est dans cette maison
qui est aujourd'hui devenu une fondation
et le livre s'ouvre sur un vol
alors c'est le vol à la fois d'un dessin
du collier des nymphéas qui est réalisé
par claude monet et c'est aussi le vol
de ce collier lui même qui l'avait fait
faire et bien par un grand bijoutier
pour sa femme alors c'est un livre très
saisissant parce qu'on est plongé comme
ça dès le début dans une intrigue
suscité agatha christie tout à l'heure
oui on est prêts d'agatha christie en 3
guette à christie et arsène lupin bonne
compagnie alors qu'ils sont vos modèles
dans l'écriture valérie vous parlez
beaucoup de juliette benzoni qui était
la reine du roman populaire historique
qu'est ce que c'est elle qui vous a
donné envie d'écrire
c'est elle que c'était mes premières
lectures d'adolescents elle a commencé à
écrire ya très longtemps donc mes
premières lectures d'adolescente
je me souviens car ça se passait à
l'époque beaucoup par série on faisait
vraiment les séries de quatre cinq six
voire dix on n'avait pas peur des
grandes séries de dix années 80 70 ce
qui ne se fait plus à charlize angélique
et compagnie qui était même à 21
contentin rappelez vous il y avait les
caroline chérie il y avait toutes ces
choses là et aujourd'hui ça fait un peu
plus peur aux éditeurs mais moi j'aimais
bien suivre sur un long terme ce qui
arrivait aux protagonistes
il fait tout drôle parce qu'il ya une
mode apple et des séries à la télévision
notamment et c'est vrai que vous avez
raison les éditeurs peut-être un peu
plus peur de ça souffle sauf que c'est
formidable
et d'ici on paie les vols chez pas les
bons ses confrères il s'est réclamé et
sur le long terme mais néanmoins j'aime
beaucoup ma série je savais que je
voulais présenter plainte sûrs notamment
les cinq produits de la ruche et puis je
voulais aussi que les vallées on est des
pros nago difficile je vous les emmenez
à peu près vrai ya toujours des choses
qui arrivent
et ça c'est l'imagination qui marche
mais moi je voulais l'emmener sur un
long terme et puis il ya un espèce
d'attachement j'ai cette chance avec mon
lectorat un attachement au près des
personnages que ce soit sur les deux
séries d'ailleurs et les femmes se
retrouvent beaucoup
dans la petite île trice pas ce qui lui
arrive des choses dans la fois
extraordinaire je fais pas face à un
crime tous les vents heureusement à
parler qu'à sydney il ya beaucoup
d'imagination beaucoup de ces vrai que
ces commandes d'éditeurs ne sais quoi
et puis les femmes se retrouvent alors
elles ont toutes envie d'un mari comme
ça qu'ils soient forts sur sa tempe et
un peu casse pieds quand on est
l'histoire
et puis ben voilà elles ont envie à
chaque fois et quand j'ai sorti le
capitaine ça qui était ensuite ça a été
une surprise parce que je n'avais pas
annoncée elles pensaient retourner sûr
je croise était numéro six s'était pas
le cas s'informer sur le capitaine ça ou
ils l'ont adopté automatiquement mon
public abeilles a basculé depuis le
public historique tuque et lisbonne
public vous savez même public
ce qui est amusant c'est que
l'historique à peu basculer sur l'
inverse ils veulent rester très sous
napoléon il leur faut des grands noms il
leur faudrait des figures des ted des
vip on prendra peut-être toute la mémé
vos premières intentions décrit mince et
c'était l'histoire
oui on va mais toute première c'était
l'histoire et j'ai jamais trouvé
l'éditeur qu'il voulait et puis ensuite
à palémon il était plutôt dans le japon
contemporain
il ya un peu touché non décline tous les
styles de polar humoristique le
psychologique l'écologie qu'elle a quand
même fait un grand effort parce que
c'était pas évident de le faire rentrer
dans une collection le que les primes à
l'environnement et pas forcément hyper
bien perçus ou compris en totalité en
tout cas je pense qu'au niveau
s'il en est un crime de sang restera un
crime de sang par rapport aux revenus à
7 10 petits frelons on peut raconter il
ya une scène d'ouverture pour l'homme à
7 à cette histoire où on voit nos
colères homériques de mener pourquoi
parce que justement il dévoile ce
tableau ce collier de nymphéas et ils
l'ont il n'a envie de l'offrir à sa
femme il l'a fait faire c'est un gros
budget ti chez chaumet il dévoile ce
tableau il ya ses amis qui sont là les
manceaux notamment et sa femme je me
résume il dit ça va pas mieux pas je
veux pas un collier comme ça ça le met
dans une fureur noire
il veut brûler le il veut brûler le
dessin
quelques uns sont encore peut-être se
dire que mes départs là on est on va on
va après sauter les sauter des années
c'étaient des siècles même mais mais
enfin quand on sait que mais presque et
mais dès le départ voilà on est pris
dans cette histoire ça n'a évidemment
vous l'avez inventé cette histoire de
totalement mais beaucoup retaper sur la
toile pour savoir où était le dessin oui
là j'ai vu et moi et moi même j'ai
regardé et j'ai vu que à la fondation
mené au vent des colliers dorés ah oui
conçu par monet dont ceux destinés s'est
pas fait par chaumet pour le non mais
c'est justement c'est très bien fait
justement il ya ont parlé de votre votre
amour de l'histoire et dont on parlera
compter évidemment tout le roman mais on
va voir que on va déporter justement de
cette histoire de l'art de l'histoire de
bonnes et de dessins qu'est-ce qui est
devenu qu'il a pris pourquoi et on va
arriver à une autre période que clive ou
passionnés sic et celle de la deuxième
guerre mondiale puisque peut-être que ce
dessin était d'aider himmler au four
s'en est emparée des ddd nazis s'en sont
emparés et peut-être qu'il est passé
entre les mains des des nazis peut-être
qu'ils veulent le récupérer aujourd'hui
parce que vous parlez d'une d'une
association ou fondante reine des
anciens nazis
celle là elle existe vraiment oui oui
tout à fait elle existe vraiment il se
trouve que j'ai été élevé par mes grands
parents qui avaient tous les deux 20 ans
42 et donc ils m'en raconter ça comme
ils m'auraient raconter les parents leur
jeunesse des années 70 c'était 40 donc
je me suis passionné pour 6 pour cette
histoire chacun vivant à la guerre de
manière différente et évidemment certain
attentisme de le relever aussi la
résistance passive en rien une plein de
choses et je sais que ma grand mère qui
est toujours vivante elle 97 ans c'est
elle qui a corrigé les dix petits
frelons une approche il m'avait pas
lectrices à 87,1 croyez moi je sais que
quand elle regarde les films de guerre
elle pousse des cris non ça c'est pas si
j'aurais fait comme s'annonce assez
pataud si ça c'est prenez seulement pour
des cons ça c est donc je me suis dit
voilà et j'ai cherché beaucoup et donc
ce et c'est encore très vivant il faut
pas croire le l'entr'aide entre
descendent en asie maintenant parce
qu'il lui devancé les ans les enfants et
notamment cette fille du maire se
considère réellement comme la
descendance la représentation de den
osse c'était effrayant mais les yeux
alors ils ont des valeurs pourtant ils
ont l'impression d'avoir des valeurs
absolument mais l'une des choses qui
vous intéressent justement dans
l'histoire et c'est pour ça que sans
doute le
cette histoire des nazis de vous
passionne c'est comment né le mal hein
ça s'est passé mais c'est une question
qu'on ait des vigiles à comprendre assez
importante et surtout quand c'est le mal
absolu
le mal absolu pourquoi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé à un moment on dit toujours
que tous les enfants naissent bons qui
sont pas méchants d'avant ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé à un moment pour que
cette personne évidemment pas bébé mais
un plus grand et bascule dans une telle
idéologie
il ya quelque chose qui s'est passé
c'est pas possible les parents
intéressés des êtres humains il ya des
êtres humains il faut pas là
et alors ce qu'est ce qu'il ya très
intéressant chez vous ou là on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure dès que patrice et
que vous prenez des personnalités
existantes
généralement vous admirez et puis
ensuite vous le voulez placer dans vos
romans par exemple l'historien donc
michel de decker le wiki est libre mais
vous le faites un moment ils
interviennent et à la fondation et ira
déchaînement des autorisations bien
entendu il a voulu dire le bouquin avant
ce qui vous fait plaisir des conneries
pas question évidemment il faut signaler
que le malheur on est désespérés
l'histoire absolument truculent bristol
rester d'un conteur d'histoires et
biographe de mode et biographe de
monnaie donc c'est sa vie aux objets et
lui et c'est là où il expliqué qui fait
d'eux des colères absolument mémorable
mais pelé bon sens de nouvelles quelque
chose oui oui donc cesser ces
personnages que comme ça que vous
admirez jeu pendant le prochain roman
mort d'une bougie on a pu voir que c'est
la fameuse commissaire daniel thierry un
que vous engagez pour votre enquête donc
il est comme ça dans vos romans vos
passions et puis il y a on peut le dire
comme ça vaut admiration je pense qu'on
tous les auteurs agissent de la même
façon c'est une façon de faire passer ce
qu'on aime se représenter soi même
peut-être un brin de mégalomanie la
sincérité
oui il ya aussi en ce qui me concerne a
très souvent moi je véhicule des
messages
alors pour l'écologique pas à ses
messages à la prime à l'environnement
fait attention il pas quatre planètes
enfin et c'est sans vouloir être rasoir
s'en vouloir
par exemple sur les flots asiatique ce
que vous racontez vos intérêts
oui et c'est vrai que bon moi et ça m'a
personnellement ils viennent
honnêtement des vents de vienne je suis
rigide tout le monde maintenant c'est
aussi une bestiole très intéressant et
je pense que pour mieux la combattre il
faut mieux la connaître
ils n'ont pas tué bêtement comme ça
voilà oui c'est injuste oui la
disparition s'est passé plein de
solutions
on va parler de willy père guy gilbert
est ce que c'est vrai que les ruines
audrey quel prénom de votre fille donc
ça doit vous avez bien c'est vous devez
vous avez inspiré par une jeune actrice
appelé le diffon temps oui oui c'est
vrai je l'avais vue et voilà je me
disais tiens si l'année voilà j'ai
d'autres clubs on la mesure à temps des
séries télévision il est bon de voir
comment et le et le lait le la jeddah en
retraite alors je sais pas qui
l'inspirent mais alors en tout cas il
connaît toutes les injures de cabinda
d'accueillir paquin au filet pour ma
jeunesse
donc voila encore quelque chose que j'ai
replacé je n'ai pas mille sabords taïba
oui mais il n'ya pas que ça et
d'ailleurs j'ai pour l'occasion on va
aller sur des sites où il y en a
vraiment plus que j'aurais pensé
analogue à huy et varier un peu pas
toujours les mêmes moules à gaufres et
évidemment aux données les principaux
débats y adhère le carnaval donc voilà
je me sers toujours de personnaliser
c'est intéressant et que j'aime beaucoup
celle pour 10 qui frôle ont bien voilà
je revendique totalement agatha christie
qui était derrière la première femme à
écrire je tu as fait ce genre de choses
et c'est une admiration pour elle parce
que je suis pas sûr qu'à l'époque
d'accord à la fonctionner d'accord ses
invendus mais je suis pas sûr que
c'était bien vous grande femme sur le
dur et b puisque le but de di fontan la
télévision est attaché non par vous aux
séries oui je pas censé lire tout de
suite fait bon flâner mise en réseau et
en faisant fermer un peu de votre
parcours parce qu'il est il est assez
étonnant donc vous êtes né dans le
département des yvelines vous avez être
achètent tout ce dont vous avez
travaillé à ces jeunes comme
démonstratrice dans des grands magasins
et puis ce un tournant important vous
êtes engagé à la fondation napoléon
comme copistes informatique des lettres
de l'empereur pour les éditions fayard
alors en quoi ça consiste à faire le
plumitif tout simplement c'est de la
copie c'est de la recopier les lettres
il y avait déjà une première édition qui
avait été fait
tout napoléon iii et puis il voulait la
remettre au goût du jour
il savait qu'il voulait d'ailleurs il y
avait des lettres qui avait été retrouvé
en a retrouvé d'ailleurs assez
constamment qui étaient dans des coffres
qui sortira j'en viens même à monsieur
arrivé avec six lettres qu'il avait
trouvé dans un coffre hérité des lacs
étaient inconnues d'ailleurs de la
fondation qui étaient ravis donc ils ne
sont pas achetées mais par contre ils
disent on scanne et photocopier pour les
avoirs des archives et puis ça
consistait donc il ya des tas de choses
parce que des fois les lettres étaient
écrites en trois quatre fois dans les
minutes dans file écrivait enfin il
faisait écrire du mois parce que les
toutes premières étaient à la joséphine
notamment ensuite il faisait écrire
jamais ce jour et est donc donc ont
recopié les lettres et par tranches ou à
qui ça s'adressait il y avait des
correcteurs qui étaient des historiens
ce qui m'a permis d'avoir accès avec des
gens ce formidable comme jacques olivier
boudon par exemple qui sortent des
livres tout le temps qui est très
intéressant aussi
donc en fonction de les destinataires et
de l'époque
moi j'ai surtout traiter la paire
millicent 6809 donc été concernés
surtout par les guerres et c'est de là
que vient vous avez déjà l'amour de
révéler où c'est de là qu'il est venu
alors oui comme il faut les dix filles
tv par mes grands parents donc non
n'allez pas au parc on allait au parc de
la même maison donc j'ai tombé dans la
volonté impériale et pas assez mal
comment la les jardins comme versailles
et tout reste était gratuit on peut y
aller facilement ce qui n'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui
alors on va raconter par coup mais c'est
vrai que après vous avez repris vos
études assez tard il passait le bac
devant la presse m
incroyable et bien ça vous avez fait des
doublés et puis après vous êtes revenu à
ce qui était quand même une passion de
votre famille c'est à dire les plis
culture oui bah le bac oui c'était un
peu ma soeur la veille au palais garnier
est abattue là-bas tu vas voir tu vas
l'avoir
bon et puis j'ai passé une époque
formidable
j'ai rencontré des gens absolument
fabuleux parce qu'on n'était qu'avec des
gens qui étaient cadrage nerfs voire
plus à la moyenne avec 65 ans c'était
une avocate qui avait besoin de ça
visiblement qu il faut saluer oui oui eh
bien vous faire lallaoui qu'ils aient
besoin va de l'anglais et puis la fac de
nanterre c'est comme meetic
c'est de là qu'est partie oui voilà ah
oui et par contre l'ambiance est restée
un on la touche encore du bois il ya
encore des graffitis d'époque
j'y étais on attendait on attendait un
sens c'est comme ça une guerre et
carrément mais tout le monde dit vous
vous dirigez toujours quelle qualité
ils vont venir et là tout le monde était
sur le pied de guerre robin tient ses
comptes
on y apprend très bien il ya des très
bons coups et j'ai tendance à lire les
nombres ça vaut pas jussieu mais si ça
vole bien sûr donc oui je reviens donc à
l'apiculture est une passion de mon
arrière-grand-père qui avait fondé son
rocher dans les années 25 30
un peu avant la guerre et puis il se
trouve qu'il est mort d'assez bonne
heure il avait un cancer en 44 ils ont
voulu opérer à l'époque un je vous dis
pas comment ça s'est fait c'était encore
plus rapide du coup
l'espace de deux mois il est parti plus
personne ne s'est occupé de ses rues il
y avait 160 toute envolée
elles sont parties et à l'époque il
était d'usagé de signaler aux abeilles
on croyait à ce genre de chose en tout
cas en auvergne puisque moi je suis
d'origine auvergnate d'aller poser un
ruban noir sur chaque ruche pour leur
indiquer que leurs bergers étaient morts
voilà donc c'est ce qui a été fait et
puis quand elles compriment pas compris
en tout cas au printemps il n'est plus
rien et donc plus personne n'a repris je
me suis dit pourquoi pas renonce pas
vous et sont comme ça que sont nées les
rochers d'eau dans des ruches et
d'audrey et vous fait que du miel
évidemment là je dis aussi donc je me
contente que du miel parce qu'en fait ça
parce que bien sûr oui l'église va faire
le stage c'est ce traître qu'il préside
de l'eau gelée royale
absolument il faut savoir qu'on ne peut
pas tout faire avec une gauche à ceux
qui prennent le pollen ceux qui font le
pollen ceux qui font la gelée ne font
généralement pas nier ne peut pas tout
leur frein sinon ça marche une saison 4
sont en chaos
alors dire un mot des lieux interlopes
bien sûr on va parler de votre autre
roman donc le plus récent est également
ce sont les diamants de waterloo la clim
est un livre qui met en scène un héros
qui est destiné à devenir récurrent si
j'ai bien compris jérôme blanc alias
capitaine sabres qui a survécu parce
qu'elle était très gravement blessée à
waterloo
il est soigné à l'hôpital du gros
caillou à paris hélas le docteur la
reine lui présente le célèbre alors
encore un autre personnage que vous
produisez françois vidocq ancien bagnard
devenu chef de la sûreté et vidocq lui
propose de devenir détective et ensemble
ils vont créer lagence de l'ours et
leurs premières missions qu'elles
étaient les biens qu'il s'agit de
retrouver les diamants volés de la
princesse borghèse la gêne cire de
napoléon alors là on va rentrer dans une
enquête encore plein de rebondissements
de surprise c'est extrêmement bien fait
bien documenté avec ce personnage
historique que vous fait revivre le
vocabulaire de l'époque encore la
normandie vous chérissez est ce que
c'est un travail très différent ici
que par rapport aux enquêtes du dre que
vous avez mené totalement c'est
totalement différent et ça nécessite
évidemment beaucoup plus de recherche et
documentation en version vous pas se
planter là n'auraient pas assez à faire
parce que je savais que les anciens
collègues de la fondation avait déjà mis
la baïonnette au canon justement venant
de quelqu'un qui avait travaillé qui
avait pu avoir accès à beaucoup de
choses
et bien lui pardonnerait pas voilà la
moindre goutte randget qui sera mal
placé et donc j'ai fait énormément de
recherches j'ai les ai soumis à
quelqu'un qui était aussi passionné
d'histoire alain siriki montgrand
correcteurs intérieur que j'appelle tout
à l'ancien prof d'histoire et de
français à la retraite ce qui permettait
aussi de corriger la syntaxe qui est pas
toujours les puisque les coulisses du
livre puis ce qui est abouti ensuite
c'est pas la même chose du tout il est
donc ça m'a permis d'apporter beaucoup
plus de choses d'ailleurs au niveau des
souvenirs de jérôme qui vont se
retrouver dans le deuxième qui sort
bientôt enfin qui sortent manière il ça
se retrouver je pense en faire une
espèce de spécificité ce qui permet de
comprendre les événements d'avant de
faire des bombes sur quinze ou vingt ans
sans faire deux trois quatre pages pour
faire un rappel c'est juste la façon qui
soit évidemment c'est une interprétation
tels que 800 souviens quand elle que lui
l'a vécu mais bon ça passe bien auprès
des lecteurs ça passe très bien
justement je l'aimais serait souvent au
présent pour ce soit pas louis parce que
sinon voilà mais c'est un vrai travail
et la fois dix tailles et de romanciers
historiens c'est très compliqué le roman
historique nous il réussissait
parfaitement juste un bon pour pour
terminer on va s'apprête à commémorer
les deux sens aux ongles disparition de
napoléon c'était le 5 mai 1821 et alors
ya des polémiques qui naissent et aux
députés de francs sera soumise qui dit
qu'au bon va pas célébrer le demi de la
république il ya deux dj mais comment il
a rétabli l'esclavagé en va pas enfin
célébrer c'est assez étonnant au faut
qu'on puisse pas faire le tri dans
l'histoire c'est à dire dire oui à des
choses il ya des choses il ya des choses
ils sont peut-être plus contestable mais
mais ça n'empêche pas que c'est de notre
histoire
enfin comment vous vivez ce genre de
polémique je le vis comme comme beaucoup
je pense que la plupart des gens sont
d'accord avec l'idée que bon trop de
guerre c'est vrai certains auraient pu
être évités bon ça n'a pas été le cas
ensuite il faut pas oublier tout ce qui
laisse quand même toutes les
institutions ont vite su ans la plupart
il vit comme enjeu de souville avengers
vista de choses beaucoup de gars de pays
européens autant de nous vivent sur ce
même code est arrangé pour leurs propres
pays et c'est amusant par contre de
constater que je suis en relation avec
des gens des pays de l'est beaucoup qui
apprécient napoléon les russes eux mêmes
les russes eux-mêmes pourtant il aurait
à dire autant là je suis en contact avec
un monsieur polonais qui me dit je ne
comprends pas il français par contre la
france installé à varsovie
je ne comprends pas ces polémiques ici
il est très admiré parce qu'il a essayé
de débarrasser la pologne de fougue
russe
et à propos de l' esclavage il faut
quand même dire oui c'est vrai il a
remis l'esclave haye c'est une erreur
totale de sa part faut pas oublier que
tous les pays fonctionnait sur ce même
la même façon la tendance à l'oublier
dit qu'on est dans une autre époque on
sillonne aujourd'hui mais il a aussi
retiré il
ces logos en laissant voir une époque où
je pense qu'ils avaient d'autres chats à
fouetter
c'est l'été
ben oui et louis xviii qui revient au
pouvoir n'en tient absolument pas compte
ils déchirent le papier et voilà on en
parle plus et tout le monde pourtant en
sens l'ouïe 18 en disant oui il a repris
derrière ils avaient du goût c'est vrai
il reste quoi faire néanmoins il aurait
pu mais prendre ce papier et s'en servir
pour faire une loi de la passe et
pourquoi parce que personne autour ne le
faisais pas ce que c'était une manne
parce que voilà faut replacer le
contexte tout simplement merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
alors j'ai appelé de livres aux éditions
palais mondon qui elle dit petit frelot
ces aides les en-cas d'audrey l'éleveuse
d'abeilles et puis les diamants de
waterloo selick banquette du capitaine
sabre et c'est aussi sur les mots merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup de talent et à
très vite pour lancer notre envie de
lecture
[Musique]